follow your own goddamn dreams not what
your mom wants you to do and what your
dad wants you to do I didn't enjoy what
I was doing and it felt like it didn't
have a purpose of me doing it so the
future for me was something really like
ah I don't even want to think about it
how bad of a situation you're in or how
much the world seems to be against you
you're not going to be like that forever
he's a Swedish based comedian and video
producer best known for his video series
on YouTube he dropped out of university
to focus on his YouTube channel much to
the dismay of his parents it worked out
though and since 2013 he has become the
number one most subscribed to youtuber
on the platform
he's PewDiePie and here's my take on his
top ten rules of success rule number one
is my personal favorite and I'm super
curious to figure out which one you guys
like the best also as you're watching
the clips if you hear something that
really resonates with you please leave
it down the comments below and put
quotes around it so other people can be
inspired as well when you write
something down it's much more likely to
stick with you to enjoy
[Music]
even if I wasn't making videos now I've
learned that I should you should really
follow your heart and you should do what
you want to do and what you are
passionate about it's the I guess I
really hard for me to talk about it but
I really was wasn't happy before because
I it felt like I didn't enjoy what I was
doing and it felt like it didn't have a
purpose for me doing it so the future
for me was something really like ah I
didn't even want to think about it and
I've learned I learned a lot from this
YouTube about myself and that I always
no matter what I want to do what I what
I love to do and what I'm passionate
about and I hope I can carry that
message on to you bro said nothing
school or anything like that but you
should definitely follow it follow what
you want to do absolutely life is too
short for doing things that you don't
like money is the topic that I
purposefully try to avoid for the five
years that I've been making videos
because I just I do feel like it's not
important to anyone and I just want to
make entertaining videos don't get me
wrong though I don't hate money I'm not
gonna pretend like it doesn't matter to
me because it matters to everyone but
when I started doing YouTube I was in
college I was on a student loan
I couldn't even afford a proper computer
that I could record gameplay on so I was
lucky I managed to sell some artwork
that I made online and that's how I was
able to get started some of you know
this story but shortly after I quit
college and so I had to get a job and I
took whatever job I could get which was
to work in a hotdog stand
and a lot of people like to take the
story as something negative or like oh
he did bad or I can't believe you used
to sell hot dogs now look at him making
big bucks it wasn't like that at all for
me I was the happiest I was at that time
because I was finally for the first time
and then
many years doing what I wanted to do and
the fact that I could make videos was so
much more important to me that I had to
spend a few hours a day doing a job that
wasn't that prestigious I didn't know
you could be being at a while I know
people who were big at other type of
videos but there was no one big at
gaming and I didn't know you could make
money out of it so it was never like a
career that I just quit college to
pursue it's just something I just love
to do and here we are five years later
and it it's exploded and what people I
guess don't really think about until
it's in their phase is that I have nine
billion views and that translates to
something there's ads of my videos I
make money out of those so whenever he
comes out how much I made a certain year
people just get so shocked and a lot of
people also which I saw were very very
angry they thought it was unfair they
thought I just sit on my ass all day and
I just yell at the screen over here
which is true but there's so much more
to it than that and I understand that
people just haters gonna hate right but
I don't know I really think that money
doesn't make you happy I am just as
happy as I am now as I was five years
ago I'm very happy that I don't have to
worry about paying rent because that was
a huge issue when my sake came over to
Sweden we could barely afford it so I'm
happy about that
but other than that it doesn't change
much everything happens for a reason I
don't believe that that would be stupid
it's a really great way to look at
things and it helps me keep the positive
attitude when you're in a bad situation
which is really hard I know a lot of
people seem to think of problems as this
horrible thing that should never happen
and anything bad happens your life is
over but really think of how boring
anyone would be if they never had to
deal with any kind of problem what kind
of boring person would that make you
problems help us grow
it helps us become better people because
we learn from them just like mistakes
but I also want to remind you that it's
totally okay to be sad from that it's
totally okay to break apart a little bit
being happy all the time is it's not
realistic and it it might actually be a
good thing just to remind you things
will always get better everything is
going to be fine
I don't care how bad it was situation
you're in or how much the world seems to
be against you you're not going to be
like that forever and if you fight
through it which I know you can it will
be worth it you just need time
everything's going to be all right
treat others treat others treat others
like you want to be treating yourself it
might seem weird how helping others will
make yourself feel better but it's been
scientifically proven that it does and
keeping a positive energy or gone around
others will keep klas will keep out your
old negative heart I have gotten more of
the YouTube than I ever could have
possibly even dreamed about I would say
try out different things and that's how
I started off because I start off doing
call of duty stuff not a lot of people
know that
fun game but I all the sudden I was like
I'm going to try something else so I try
playing this horror game and that's
where I think being my initial boom
started from trying something else so
how many spoons you can browse the site
what's the point of this my job is so
easy I can really do what I feel like
and kind of amazing just the fact that I
can play video games for a living that
when I realized that for the first time
like I was almost getting teary I like
it was my dream has come true all the
time and it bonamana you know be happy
not to be number one I'm like what I'm
just a nerd who plays video games I
don't I didn't seek the spotlight how
you look at yourself I get a lot of
messages from you bro saying you're not
happy with who you are you look like
you're overweight I don't know and to be
honest it's not something I know how to
help with because I don't really
struggle with it I feel content with who
I am and I want you to feel the same way
by any means I'm not slowing so it's not
about that it's about being happy with
who you are people point out my flaws
all the time especially since I'm on the
Internet things that I didn't even know
what the problem and
until people told me like my forehead is
too big I am a giant mole here which you
might not be able to see my nose is too
white my my chin is too was like long
and lean ocean not muscular enough all
these things people tell me and maybe
doesn't make me happier but thing is
what anyone has to say about you and how
you look no one has a goddamn right to
point out anything about your appearance
which gives you every single right not
to give up what anyone else has to say
about it your parents will tell you you
can be whatever you want to be in life
which is true but what a lot of times
they don't tell you is that you have to
work really hard to get there and
another thing maybe more importantly is
that you have to take risk you have to
win venture into the unknown and you
might not know what's going to happen
and that's scary but I think it's always
better to try the not trying no matter
what except men not not even one I'm
going to feel like I could get an editor
and I could get some help with different
production and stuff like that but I'm
still the one doing everything by myself
and I wanted to keep it that way and I
want that to be kind of like an
inspiration for you broke maybe I wanted
to you bros to feel like hey pills can
do it I can do it good you have any
dream or hopes out there you can just be
like well if pills can do it I can do it
because I don't know I like to be more
proud of myself and being proud was I
got help doing I guess I don't know
follow your own goddamn dreams not what
your mom wants you to do what your dad
wants you to do not what you think you
should be doing but doing what you want
to do more than anything it's I it's
been said so many times before but
really if you don't make your own
decisions in life someone else is going
to make them for you and that by the end
of it you won't be happy you might as
well do what it is you want to do I
think in general people probably see you
to us some it's very simple anyone can
do it and I think that's really cool but
it is a lot of work for it and I agree I
work a lot to get to our amps I don't
want people to just go into it and just
think they and they couldn't do it right
away because with it you can do anything
you want if you if you work hard you got
to be a little locket too and I think
I've been in as well
that bridge it's Alan maybe you want to
wait but things fail but you can't just
bail when things quick
but I will let nothing
well it's motor learning cream is their
world what the [ __ ] am i doing I'm sorry
what is talking
oh god this is no wine I know how I
Oh God no no no don't look at me you
like it you like it [ __ ] don't you
Oh anger is oh my god
Megan I don't know
[Music]
holy [ __ ] I'm nailing it that's right
yeah that's why witness dancing history
in progress
why did you keep cutting her body like
that goddamn sucked in the nineties man
forget a heart attack just write on my
gravestone that identified with me
oh god what is that so awkward enough
come on Karl already ready released a
second
yes
hope you enjoyed I'm gonna go lie down
for a love that just on doesn't run Oh
you bye thank you so much for watching I
made this video because Christian Vargas
asked me to so there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave it down the comments below I
will see what I can do
I'd also love to know what did you learn
from PewDiePie today and that's going to
have the biggest impact on your life on
your business that you're going to
immediately apply I'd love to hear from
you please leave it down the comments
below and I'm going to join in the
discussion finally I want to give a
quick shout out to DS Martinez thank you
so much for picking up a copy of my book
your one word it really really really
means a lot to me in that picture you
took with the mirror is awesome and I
love it so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one where it is let's love
I'll see you soon